this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck this podcast
has bad words
hello simpletons welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalist now Ryan we talked
for a long time last week with Jamie
kill Steen about toxic people yes and we
had so many questions I thought we'd do
is sort of follow up it's a standalone
episode you don't have to go back and
listen to that one I certainly would
recommend it it's one of my favorite
episodes we've ever done it's great and
also the the maximal episode two that is
top two patreon episodes we've ever done
a private podcast episodes it was
phenomenal so go back and listen to
those if you'd like however if you don't
want to this is gonna be a standalone
episode we're gonna talk about negative
people now negative people often lead to
toxic relationships or toxic people I
want to try to delineate two to a little
bit yeah that's interesting cuz toxic
people are probably negative yes but
negative people aren't necessarily toxic
maybe they're on the path to I am yeah
so we're talking about that we're
talking about why we're addicted to
negativity we're gonna talk about gossip
we're gonna talk about some
disempowering emotions and behaviors and
we're gonna talk about what we can do to
improve or walk away from and negative
situations so I feel like we've covered
a lot last week but we should just go
ahead and dive right in to our questions
today
you know the first one is from Shannon
in Salt Lake City for the past couple of
years when my sister-in-law and her
family had visited us her and her
husband made comments about our
simplified home the comments are snide
an example would be something like does
your minimalist lifestyle allow for an
extra blanket in the house or do we have
to go buy one before we come out but in
fact we have extra blankets and pillows
but not an overabundance of them like we
used to
I've tried intended to explain my simple
living approach to them that have
received a lot of i rolling and laughter
in response
another detail to this situation is that
my husband is sensitive to their remarks
because he still gauges his success as a
provider on how much we own so he
doesn't have my back on this
unfortunately since he's still not 100%
on board with it yet so with another
family visit coming up very soon I'm
anxious to hear what suggestions you
guys may have for me as far as a
response to their remark Ryan what's
fascinating here is you and I can make
sort of joking comments with each other
all the time we can rib each other in
fact I I think quite often that is the
the marker of a really robust strong
relationship I t's only the people who I
really feel comfortable teasing right
otherwise I'd be a real jerk if I just
went around the random people in the
hallways of this this office building
him like hey nice shoes what are those
like it wouldn't work as well I was
literally thinking the same exact and so
before even I just picture you walking
around what are those yeah so so here's
the thing right III think there's a sort
of comments that the teasing will call
it she called them snide the teasing
comments there are there's a welcomed
version of that and there is a unwelcome
version of that right and right now it
seems like it's unwelcome now it's only
unwelcome because you are not welcoming
it right and so maybe look inwardly
first and and try to determine Shannon
are these people maybe they're trying to
find a way to warm up to me I'm trying
to give the charitable acts but that
approach yeah here right because maybe
what they're really trying to do is
trying to identify with you and all
they're they're really doing is
projecting their insecurities onto you
but they're doing so in a way they're
where they're actually exposing their
insecurities and they're trying to in a
way to relate with you like you know I'm
what I'm really saying is I have too
many blankets or I have too many pillows
or I have too much stuff in my closets
or whatever and and the way that's going
to manifest is by me teasing you like
I'll do that with Ryan's are you wearing
your what are those shoes right now yes
yeah
and so Ryan has like these what can only
be described as Jesus sandals lu0 shoes
right yeah and and so like I can tease
him for that because first of all I like
them actually and he knows that I like
them I can't pull them off personally
and so really what I'm saying is man I
wish I could pull those off but they're
wet the way for me to do that in my own
way is to be like I have to rip you for
it yeah it's interesting when I when I
hear to talk about our in-laws ribbing
her like this to me it sounds like her
in-laws there's some insecurity that's
going if they're not joking yeah and
they're in they're actually trying to be
snide then there's some insecurities
going on and I think you know with any
relationship whether it's a toxic
relationship or a negative relationship
the first step is to try and fix it and
I think the path to fixing relationships
like this is first off like don't get
defensive you know think about how if
you know if your in-laws Shannon if they
say something tonight think about how
you can turn it around and make it a
joke like when someone comes to me and
they're like and I'm in the grocery
store I have a bunch of lemons and
they're like oh that's not a very
minimalist amount of lemons I'll be like
yeah this is all I could fit in my arms
like I was trying to get twice as much
but I and I'm like I'll just like kind
of turn it around like that and if you
if you if you don't get defensive and
you try and tackle it with humor that is
one approach now another approach is
let's say that you know if it's really
bothering you and your husband it's
totally appropriate to set some
boundaries of your in-laws and say hey
look I've tried to get by your comments
with jokes I've tried to you know not
let it affect me but when you make
comments like that it really damages our
relationship and I really want us to
have a strong relationship so in order
to do that you know please please try to
keep your snide comments to yourself I
mean there's a lot of different
approaches here I know do with you and
me it's like we can rib each other yeah
but like if I call you a dummy like
joking around you're like dude I don't
like that yeah and I'm like oh okay
right I respect that
well we're respectful of each other and
by the way that respect allows us to be
able to go really far with the ribbing
like yeah you and I take things way
slower so far that you know these
comments like in your right rhyme people
will run into me in the airport like oh
look at that bag you have it sure is a
lot of stuff you're carrying minimalist
or when you were going to the movies at
the Grove Oh God
you got like a crowd of people taunting
me I think I talked about that so just
real quick I went to the Grove to go
watch a movie by myself my family was
out of town I'm all by myself I'm like
I'm gonna go watch a movie
in the movie I wanted to watch was only
at the Grove which is most movie
theaters are in shopping centers yeah
and the Grove is like this upscale
shopping mall in like Beverly Grove and
and so I I Drive there I park as soon as
I get off the elevator on the first fly
walk up to the the map to see where the
theater is guys never been to the Grove
and as soon as I go to the map and this
guy walks up hey minimalist what are you
doing here I didn't think minerals would
go to a shopping mall and I'm like okay
I go okay haha and and then he's like
well hey I'll walk you to the movie
theater then like okay that's kind of a
nice train some people don't know like
boundaries or whatever and and so and
along the way I was just recognized by
like six people including the guy so
five other people and it's this it's
this weird feeling but at the same time
it will bring out a insecurity in me
because if I really was at the mall just
shopping and like living in congruous by
the way I'm not saying there's anything
wrong with them all if I want to go to
Nordstrom and buy a pair of shoes
there's nothing inherently wrong with
that as long as I do so intentionally I
see sean writing something down don't
put Nordstrom in the shownotes Sean
anyway Ryan I wanted to bring up a
couple other things for Shannon is you
and your husband need to get on the same
page I know he has some insecurities but
he's really gonna need to man up here
and he's going to and by the way if this
is your husband calling in I would say
that you need to man up on this as well
so it's not gender specific you you need
to take responsibility because your
partner should be the most precious your
partnership should be the most precious
relationship and you need to be willing
to stand up for each other as long as
you're not doing something that is toxic
or negative toward
people yeah and it's his family so it is
kind of his responsibility to help his
wife set the boundaries like hey you're
my family this is my partner yeah and
here are the boundaries that I would
really appreciate you know you follow to
help us have a good household and good
relationship when you're here the best
way to get on the same page the best way
to help your husband man up is go out of
your way to show him respect to show
them appreciation to show him
understanding don't take out your
frustration on your husband that's like
the worst thing you can do yeah that'll
tear down the relationship yeah so go
out of your way to to really form a team
with your husband and ask for his help
yeah that's you know I I think try the
lion-hearted approach first Shannon like
first like just take their snide
comments and double down on them do you
have any extra pillows and blankets no
we got rid of everything you're actually
gonna be sleeping on the backboard right
exactly and if you start teasing them
back I think that's a wonderful approach
because it shows that you don't take
that the you don't take it that
seriously I mean that's the one thing
about me and Ryan with the whole
minimalism thing it's like we don't take
any of this that seriously yeah and and
it's because what is truly important has
nothing to do with like these little
cavils that your family's thrown at you
and by the way there's not a rule that
says you have to get along perfectly
with your husband's family you're in
this partnership not because of his
extended family and the relationships
you have
in fact Ryan now you've talked in the
past at least briefly about you've
stayed in a relationship before because
you really like the person's Parham
that's like my biggest downfall with my
long-term failed relationships is I
really loved my partner's family more I
love my partner right yeah so that's
yeah that's the opposite there yeah and
well I'm in a similar situation right
now it vexes family and i we don't not
get along but like we just it's oil and
water if for whatever reason like I like
them I think they're perfectly fine
there are other there are other people
I've dated where like they're worse I'm
simpatico with the woman's father or I'm
simpatico with both parents and I still
get like my birthday was two days ago
and I was getting text messages from
like parents of former lovers even
though the lovers weren't texting me I'm
getting like detects hey Josh I really
just hope you're you're doing well
really proud of what you're doing with
your podcast and it's like wow we
haven't talked in a year since my last
birthday or whatever but like the point
is that the family is not what make it
was not what empowers your relationship
it's a really great cherry on top if you
can really get along with the family
yeah and it's even better if you could
just or at least you don't want to have
a negative family that is tearing down
your relationship and right now it seems
like his family is seemingly
unintentionally having a strain on your
relationship yeah you and your husband
need to get on the same page so you can
fix that strain and at the same time
maybe look at yourself and say how can I
handle this more eloquently yeah the one
thing the one warning I want to give
Shannon is when you're you know trying
to make light of their comments and
you're trying to bring the mood up when
maybe they're trying to like me bring
the mood down be careful with being
passive-aggressive like you don't want
that ribbing back to become this form of
passive-aggressive comments because that
will also hurt the relationship so
there's I don't know where that line is
but I think you can determine that by
looking at your intent like are you
intending to hurt them back or are you
intending to actually make light of this
situation if your intent is to hurt them
back that's that's the wrong approach
yeah you also remember you get what you
tolerate and so if you're just gonna
keep tolerating a bad behavior on them
you're from them you're going to keep
getting it yeah and so something is
going to have to change here Shannon let
me give you a copy of our book
minimalism live a meaningful life it's
the first book that Ryan and I wrote we
rewrote it a few years ago and there's a
relationship chapter in there in
particular that identifies the three
types of relationships in our lives and
it also explains how we can recategorize
the people in our life so if you can
identify that you have a hundred and
fifty relationships in your life that's
Dunbar's number then you can say okay
which which people fall into each
category of relationships and why and
then how can i reprioritize these so
that my relationships will thrive
that's minimalism live a meaningful life
and we'll send you the audiobook I feel
like our podcast you'll love the
audiobook version of minimalism or if
you want the book book or the e-book
we're happy to send those to you as well
Shannon alright our next question is
from Kayla and Milwaukee I'm having a
work issue and I can't go to an HR
department unfortunately because it's
such a small company there's no one I
can go to and the person with the
problem is actually my boss and the
owner and long story short it's a very
sexist environment and it's beyond
inappropriate it's completely
unprofessional and I'm in the process
with my husband of trying to get out of
debt and doing the whole B Ramsay plan
and things were working really well but
we still have a year and a half left on
our debt you know get out of debt plan
and I'm not really sure but guilts that
I feel for quitting this job even though
I feel like it's so morally wrong to
stay here you know is that guilt valid
then for leaving because we are trying
to get out of debt I just feel so guilty
leaving even though this position is so
so unacceptable and I just I there are
days where I just can't do it anymore
and I just want to throw my shoes out
and walk out the door so how do I deal
with that that stress that guilt but
then at the same time hating going to
work because I just can't believe that
this is what's going on in this
workplace so Ryan 'sounds looked to me
like Kayla's boss is doing something
that is certainly immoral I don't know
whether or not he's doing something
illegal if he's doing doing something
illegal I'm not an expert on the law
then of course you should take the
appropriate legal steps I want to caveat
it with that sure let's assume for the
purposes of this conversation he's just
a jerk we've had some jerk bosses before
yes and not illegal to be a jerk
unfortunately no and so we often confuse
immoral with illegal and and the
opposite is is unfortunately true saying
well it's not illegal so I'll go ahead
and do it yeah and it's like well just
because something isn't illegal it
doesn't mean it's the right thing to do
and I mean that specifically for Kayla
because where she is right now is it may
be wrong for you to stay if I'm in your
shoes I'm gonna have to ask this
question if you didn't have a job right
now kayla is this the job you would take
yeah and if the answer is no then why
you still there and well I think the
answer is well because I'm trying to pay
off my debt okay well let me ask you
this are you willing to sacrifice your
ethics your morals are you willing to
make that compromise in order to pay off
your debt the easy answer to that is no
of course not I think it's great to make
some sacrifices and some compromises in
our life I think we have to do that
especially when you're in this crater of
debt paying off debt you may have to
work a job you dislike I'm okay with
that to get out of debt long-term I'm
not okay with that I think it's terrible
to continue to work a job that you
strongly dislike or hate even I believe
she use the word hate I wouldn't use
that yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't stay
there if if it was a long term plan but
short term it makes sense as long as you
were not compromising your morals your
values right yeah unfortunately this is
one of the situations where you know
she's skirting the line of she literally
said morally wrong in the voicemail yes
so she's skirting the line of
compromising her morals to gain
financial freedom and there's a lot of
choices like this in life if it was as
easy as hey Kayla you're gonna start
killing puppies with this job like she
could be like oh I'm not gonna do that
right and leave this is a lot more
difficult but it still falls on the side
of morally wrong and I totally agree
with you Josh like if it's morally wrong
Kayla like are you gonna feel good after
a year and a half of being there the
first step to Kayla's tequilas a problem
here is I think she asked he got on the
same page with her husband so she needs
to go to her husband and say hey look I
am at a crossroads right now I either
continue to stay in this morally wrong
job and we pay off that or I'm gonna
have to go to my boss and ask him to
help me set some boundaries and if he
doesn't do that I have to leave so once
she is on the same page with her husband
whether she you know gets support to
leave or whatever it may be then she can
go to her boss and say hey look um I
really don't you know I really don't
feel like I'm being treated fairly in
this job I feel like there's a lot of
things that
our borderline you know going against my
morals and I really would like your help
that I'd like your help to set some
boundaries in fact Kayla like whenever
you're whenever you're approaching
something like this in life like all the
positive are all the negative comments
you want to put on yourself I feel like
my morals are being you know compromised
I feel like maybe there's a better way
for us to have a better work environment
and then when you're talking to your
boss you're gonna say things like you
know I I think you're a respectable boss
whatever compliment you can give him and
I know because you remember honest cop
yeah whatever honest compliment you can
give him you know here yeah you're you
are a boss that I know that you have
some integrity and I know that you're
gonna be willing to help me set these
boundaries because of the integrity that
you have whatever the honest compliment
is but you can totally approach your
boss and ask the set boundaries if your
boss well again what Josh said if he's
doing something illegal then take a
legal action if he's just being a jerk
and he refuses to stop being a jerk then
yeah it's this is up to you can you live
with yourself that's the question and if
he's being sexist I mean right now you
just have to realize that that there are
other places that you can go of course
our friend Ken Coleman who I'll
recommend his book the proximity
principle in fact his radio show he's on
a 50 markets but you can find him on
YouTube I was just having a conversation
with him a few days ago
and I mean if you're really looking to
to change your path the best time to
find a job is when you already have a
job yeah you don't want to wait till
you're gone so now is the time to find
something you what about the pandemic
what about the the crisis yeah you know
what there are still companies that are
hiring right now in fact there are some
companies that are hiring more people
and Ken talks about this on his show all
the time in fact the people who call in
to his show quite often the dilemma
they're facing is very similar to what
kayla is facing that specific
circumstance but hey I'm dissatisfied
with the career I'm in I can keep going
down this path for another year two
years five years I know this isn't the
path I want to go down well if this
isn't the path you want to go down you
need to find a new
yeah and and now is a great time it's
much better to do it now than it will be
ten years from now yeah and if you stay
where you're at right now doing
something you dislike for the next five
or ten years you will regret it and
Kayla I don't want to undermine how
difficult this is because if your boss
isn't willing to help you set some
boundaries then you're probably gonna
have to leave and in order to leave like
Josh said you've got to look for
something different and trying to look
for a new job when you're in a current
job it's really really difficult right
so yes it's gonna be a lot of hard work
Kayla but if you if you do that hard
work you're gonna feel so much better
about yourself then if you were to just
throw your hands in the air and say well
I guess I had to deal with it for the
next year and a half yeah yeah by the
way congratulations for working toward
paying off your debt yeah sounds like
you and your husband are on the same
page here I think that's I think it's
really important I think it's even more
important to not compromise our values
in order to pay off debt because here's
the thing you could go rob a bank uh pay
off your debt right now right well why
aren't you doing that Kayla
well because it's illegal okay is that
the only reason so if it was illegal to
rob a bank you would go rob a bank right
now yeah again we confuse illegal with
immoral and amoral with illegal they
might have some overlap that Venn
diagram there's certainly some overlap
there but just because something is
legal doesn't mean it's the right thing
for you to do Kayla I want you to walk
away I'm gonna send you a copy of
everything that remains here I'll hold
it up for the YouTube audience here it's
my favorite book that we've ever written
although who knows love people you love
people use things might be the new
favorite we'll see it only time will
tell
but uh everything that remains is our
story Ryan to my story of walking away
walking away from the corporate world
walking away from debt walking away from
stuff walking away from most importantly
our identities and so that's another
thing for Kayla to think about here is
part of the reason you might be saying
is your identity might be wrapped up in
this job this career as well guess what
you can you can tweeze out the most
useful bits your skills your your
talents etc and you can apply them
somewhere else so I'm gonna send you a
copy of everything there
either the the audiobook the ebook or
the book book version whichever one of
those you would like Kayla Ryan what
time is it it's time for our lightning
round where we answer your text messages
text your questions and comments to nine
three seven two zero two four six five
four yes indeed those texts go to both
of our phones I wanted to share one with
you real quick Ryan so we have this
saved here on my computer so people text
us we often answer you directly just
straight from our phones not just on the
podcast although we answer some
questions on the podcast as well we have
hundreds actually thousands of people
who text us and we try to respond to as
many people as we can especially during
this quarantine we've responded to just
about everyone at this point I'll leave
out this person's last name because
these are private conversations right so
this person's name Stephanie and
Stephanie says good morning my name is
Stephanie and I love your podcast a
message I want to let Josh know that I
actually appreciate you talking about
sex and sex toys I've had several people
text me on this and say hey what was the
tell me about somebody like tell me
about that taint tickler you were
talking about that's five times that
anyway I've had I've had people reach
out in a way like they wouldn't reach
out maybe on Twitter or something
because it is riving it is it and that's
why I'm not you know obviously putting
this person's full name out there so she
says I went on to the website you
recommend love honey and you mentioned
on your quarantine conversation with
your wife I ordered some fun things and
my husband and I have been enjoying the
addition yeah she said it's a good
reminder that monogamy doesn't mean
boring and she's also Ryan I appreciate
and respect your privacy about the topic
thank you for sharing your life with us
through each through your podcast book
and films so and then what we also do is
every Monday we send out a Monday
morning a minimal Maxim to people so
it's a a way to start off your week with
a a simple slice of simplicity so a
little maximum like build a lifestyle
around life not style that was one of
the the most recent ones and so we do
text back as many people as we can now
Ryan there
lightning-round this is where we answer
every question with just a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pith the answers
on social media if you like now you can
find all of our minimal Maxim's in one
place minimal Maxim's dot-com all right
Brian writes in how do i tactfully
handle people who constantly judge me
and overstep personal boundaries well
let's talk about boundaries this is a
this minimal maximum I'm going to give
you here is actually a line from love
people use things or our next book and
it's there's a section in there about
establishing boundaries and the line is
you can establish a boundary without
erecting a fence and and so I want you
to think about that right now there are
boundaries you already have boundary
physical boundaries right now if you
live Brian if you live in a house then
you have a boundary a property boundary
right now you don't have to have a fence
there but there is a boundary there but
you have other boundaries as well your
house has walls right those are
boundaries that you set up you have a
door on your house isn't that a boundary
now I bring that up because quite often
Ryan we feel bad I don't want to put up
put up boundaries but do do any of us
feel bad for having a door on our house
no we don't it's actually courteous
because it keeps the people out that we
don't want in and it allows us to have a
that door allows us to let people in as
we see fit so you can have boundaries
and in your life without needing to just
set up a fence that keeps everyone out
yeah you know when you're setting up
boundaries it's really easy to put the
blame on other people who you're trying
to set boundaries up with and and maybe
you know there is a there is some blame
that can be placed but when you're
setting up these boundaries it's
important to approach it in a in a love
kind respecting way because that's the
only way you're going to get someone to
respect your boundaries so my pet the
answer is encouragement is more powerful
than criticism so don't don't approach
it in a way Brian of you need to do this
you need to do that it's more of a hey
you're such a good friend I know kind of
what I was saying to Kayla earlier like
when she's gonna have the conversation
with her boss you're gonna go to this
person you're gonna say hey you're such
a good friend
know that you're gonna help me set up
boundaries and you're gonna respect them
because you love me
and you care about me and you want to
see me thrive and I want to do the same
for you
so let's set these boundaries up and
sometimes there are boundaries Ryan that
that you need to erect for some people
offense they're sometimes their own
offense where absolutely where if this
person is trying to take you down if
they're trying to tear you down and this
even goes for family members you don't
have to make room for that you could
still approach them positively in fact I
think it's better to do that than to get
into the mud with them because if you
get into the mud with them you yourself
you're going to get dirty and and so I
think that it is definitely possible for
you to to at least have this
conversation first about the negativity
you can approach them in a way where
you're setting up boundaries if the
boundaries that you set don't work what
that means is you might have to create
some distance between you and and the
negativity now it may take someone 10
years to come around 15 years to come
around but you don't have to let them
you know that the the analogy Ryan I
don't know if you've ever seen a
lifeguard save someone but now I have it
who can't I've only seen it once but who
can't they save the flailing person all
right right so so if a lifeguard jumps
into the ocean to save someone and the
person is flailing do you know what the
lifeguard is trained to do push them
away yeah and why is it about die right
and because it seems it seems callous at
first like if you push that person away
they you're killing them no I'm not
they're killing themselves mm-hmm and if
I embrace them as they're killing
themself I might die in the process yeah
now that might happen to you as well
Brian at least not not not literal I
could happen literally but I what I'm
saying is figuratively metaphysically
they might drag you down with them and
so that lifeguard in that moment creates
the boundary by extending the hand or
the leg to push them away and says hey
until you're done panicking I cannot
save you panicking whatever it is that
that's the negative behavior until
you're doing until you stop doing this
negative behavior I can't
help you one other bit of advice here if
you're trying to help them Ryan if you
reach out to a loved one a sibling a
cousin whoever and you try to help them
and they they take your words of
encouragement your words of wisdom your
altruism yeah they they take it and they
crumble it up into a ball and throw it
on the ground
stop with the words of wisdom stop with
the encouragement because Ryan brought
up a great point it's better to be
encouraging but if they take your
encouragement and they step on it well
they've just asked you that they've
shown you right there that they don't
value the value that you bring to the
table yeah and the best thing you can do
at that point is to stop and try a
different approach I just had a thought
of well because this goes back to our
toxic people episode where we talked
about trying to show people compassion
when they're when they're being toxic
and it's the same thing can be said with
compassion if they're crumbling up your
compassion and stepping on it if someone
toxic is doing that then yeah you've got
to step away yeah and maybe love someone
from a distance but and almost could be
the most compassionate thing you can do
for them yeah I'm almost wondering if
it's a better minimum maximum compassion
is more powerful than criticism I don't
know Shawn you pick up which one's
better oh I do like that yeah I think
that's a good that's a good at it Ryan
we've got a bunch more listener tips and
we got a great added value segment today
but first we have a bunch more surprise
questions
how would Marie Kondo deal with
negativity how do you prevent other
people's negativity from turning you
negative when is it a good idea to spend
time with negative family members how do
you let go of negative relationships
with love and peace without holding hate
in your heart and how do we replace
negative people with positive people
Plus Ryan we're going to talk about 13
lifes 13 most overrated virtues and and
one of those is actually negativity and
you might think well how is negativity
and overrated virtue well we're gonna
talk about it a lot of people actually
hold negativity as a virtue and we're
gonna talk about about why that's wrong
we got a million more questions about
negativity and if you want to hear all
that check out our max
episodes on the minimalist private
podcast it is a completely separate
podcast feed and it's just a couple
bucks and it's most honest way for the
minimalist to earn an income because we
don't believe in advertisement so we
make money if and only if you find value
in and support what we create and so
that allows us to pay Shawn and Jordan
and Jess and the rest of the team and me
and Ryan as well and it keeps our
podcast 100% advertisement free head on
over to the minimalists comm slash
support to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app I just got to say this real quick
Ryan the private podcast is really just
this expanded version it but it's a
different thing from the podcast it's a
much deeper dive it's much more personal
it's much more raw and and these are
longer episodes every week as well so
every Thursday we put out a private
podcast episode and and our most fervent
supporters are over there engaged and
listening and by the way that's really
the place that we accept feedback as
well where you can you can give us
feedback you can talk about the the
episode that we just recorded you can
say hey I think I really liked what you
guys did here but you missed out on on
the opportunity to to answer this
question it's really the only feedback
we listen to well right it's because we
know these people have the feedback
coming from a caring place yeah they're
invested yeah and it's not to say that
someone on YouTube isn't caring but it's
hard to make to discern the the feedback
from the the criticism of trolls and so
so our private podcast is really this
endeavor that allows us to go deep with
about 5 or 6,000 people at this point so
that we we can what we can provide this
regular podcast free to everyone to the
masses and then we dive much deeper on
the private podcast the minimalists comm
slash support because let's face it Ryan
we don't want to start talking about
mattresses and what else what were they
and should I heard insurance or sex toy
companies to sponsor us oh joy sex toy
mm-hmm all right Ryan what else you got
for us this week here are some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners hey
Josh and Ryan
Brad in New York here I have suggestions
of people trying to get rid of items he
doesn't necessarily have to be a
physical object deleting superfluous
apps from your phone can count to
digital clutter is still clutter hey
guys my name is Justin and I'm calling
from Columbus Ohio hopefully you guys
are aware in your home home state of
Ohio that the opioid prescription crisis
is at a all-time high when it comes to
the abuse and misuse of prescription
medication and one of the things that's
been developed through the Ohio State
University is a program called
generation rx and one of the key
takeaways is educating the public about
the proper use of prescription
medication as well as a proper disposal
of getting listening to your guyses
podcast and learning about some of the
principles that you guys are teaching on
it can be applied to as a potential
solution for this crisis and by applying
me simplifying and minimalizing your
drug cabinet or your medicine cabinet
and going through and properly disposing
of prescription medications that aren't
being used because one out of four
people that misuse or abuse of
prescription drug got them from a family
member or friend a lot of times that's
just prescription drugs that are hanging
out in the medicine cabinet no that can
be minimized when they're no longer
needed alright Joe for our added value
segment today I got a couple things
right
one is this book nonviolent
communication since we're talking about
dealing with negative people um on our
podcast actually had I don't recommend
on the podcast if she recommended it
after the podcast but I do remember her
mentioning and so I went and got the
book and ended up quoting from it and
love people use things to talk about
setting up boundaries and communicating
with people non-violently and and the
the author of Marshall Rosenberg
describes what what he means by
nonviolent communication but it's a
great way to to approach these
interpersonal scenarios in a way that
you can you can learn more about the
person's perspective but you can also
constructively engage with someone else
in a way that isn't blaming it's not
assuming it's productive yeah and so
nonviolent communication will put a
length of that in the show notes and
then also Ryan there is a video we
shared on social media this week called
we want your poop legal matter
transplant yes is that the nonprofit you
were talking about yeah and so there's
this guy who I'll get a little personal
right now even though we're on a minimal
episode you know a lot of I still do
have quite a few but I'm Way better than
I was a year ago a lot of gut issues
after this food poisoning event that
happened in Brazil in late 2018 and 2019
was the worst year of my life as a
result tried a lot of things including
FM T's fecal microbiota transplants and
there is a new I believe it's a
non-profit was a new organization
microbiome and if you go to the
minimalists comm slash poop you can find
the video it's just it'll just take you
right over to YouTube this guy is paying
people for their poop because what he's
trying to do so a fecal microbiota
transplant sounds crazy it's it's you're
you're putting someone else's microbiome
well it is crazy but it shows you how
how much of a last resort it is it shows
you like how bad someone situation is if
they've got to do maybe but I think it's
actually not that crazy we've been doing
it for four to six thousand years as
human beings maybe even longer and the
reason we've been we've been doing it is
because it's effective yeah
basically so your your fecal matter Ryan
if you go use the bathroom about 50% of
that there are microorganisms it's
bacteria and it's it's essentially a
probiotic on steroids and I mean
big-time Ronnie Coleman steroids right I
mean it's just these are this is about
it Laura in there yeah yeah yeah I mean
trillions and so what what you're doing
what they're trying to do with these
fecal microbiota transplants is they are
helping people who suffer from gut
issues who suffer from colitis who also
suffer from depression we're seeing
people getting their bipolar disorders
cured and you'll see in that video I
think it's a 4-minute video though
komm slash poop and I get nothing for
telling you this I just want to bring it
because I really respect what this guy
is doing Michael he started this this
organization to try to help people
because there aren't organizations out
there who are really helping people
procure good poop and it's it's
surprisingly difficult to find good poop
because we're all so unhealthy what does
the 83 or 84 percent of us are very
unhealthy and so if you or someone you
know it would consider saving someone's
life with your poop I would encourage
you to go check it out the minimalists
com a slash poop and you could literally
save someone's life or at least
radically improve their their well-being
real quick for right here right now oh
that was that was my right here right
now the the poop video so check that out
I'm gonna list a comma slash poop you
can follow the minimis on Facebook
Twitter and Instagram at the minimalists
come to one of our live podcast shows
visit the minimalists com a slash tour
to find a city near you
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email a
voice memo to podcast at the minimalists
com comment on this episode youtube.com
slash the minimalist and if you want our
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over the minimalists com you
also receive our simple Sunday emails
whenever we send them if you leave here
today with just one message we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works
they still listen y'all we'll see you
next time minimus